how many of you would at least on  occasion like to be out of the  relationship you're in  [Music]  relational intelligence is the set of  skills that we bring to knowing how to  live our relationships and i prefer it  to emotional intelligence  i've been practicing psychotherapy for  over 35 years working primarily with  couples and families  would you say coming out of your  childhood that you were more in need of  connection and protection or more in  need of freedom and individuality  everybody wants connection and everybody  needs separateness  you talk to me about a problem that  you're having and i register it like i  have to do something and how many of you  have heard yourself say i don't want you  to fix it i just want you to hear it  listening is plenty of doing  relational intelligence is the key to  our sociability it's an essential tool  for living in this world  i'm ester perel  and this is masterclass  you